the 21 year old man accused of killing
five people at a bank in Central Florida
is due in court this morning police say
Zeff and saver opened fire inside at a
Sun Trust Bank in Sebring that's nearly
100 miles south of Orlando mark
Strassmann is in Sebring where police
say they'll reveal more information
later today mark good morning good
morning the local police chief called a
cold-blooded murder a suspect wearing a
t-shirt that showed four grim reapers on
horseback walked into this Bank ordered
people to the floor and started shooting
you can see the smashed up entrance to
the bank where police stormed inside and
put a stop to it this local community is
in shock today it's been a tragic day in
our community at 12:36 p.m. police here
got a startling 9-1-1 call someone had
walked into a SunTrust Bank branch and
shot five people
the caller was the gunman you've
suffered a significant loss at the hands
of a senseless criminal doing a
senseless crime when police arrived the
gunman was barricaded inside the
standoff was tense an armored police
vehicle rammed the building while
engaged negotiations
I ordered the sheriff to send in the
tactical unit or their SWAT team in an
attempt to recover potential victims and
take the subject into custody 21 year
olds F and Xavier was led out in
handcuffs captured without police firing
a shot Florida Governor Ron de Santos
this is an individual visa face very
Swift and exacting justice local
businesses and schools were put on
lockdown friends and family members
waited at a nearby hotel for information
about who had been killed I just started
freaking out and started crying it was
like there's no way be her Jose Sanchez
is heartbroken
a close friend worked at the bank and he
has no idea whether she was inside he
didn't have to shoot them people at all
there was just innocent people just
living alive providing for their family
like we all do everyday they had no idea
today was their last day and it really
hurts me it hurts
because we're not just a community
wordfriends we all know each other
savor was trained to be a prison guard
until he quit this month he could face
the death penalty if convicted in these
five senseless killings Gail thank you
very much mark